tout a commencé ici il ya 25 ans à
l'usiné à chapeaux de rambouillet les
six membres de debout sur le zinc se
sont rencontrés au lycée rambolitains ou
à la fac de versailles
particularité chacun joue de plusieurs
instruments ou sur les axes un groupe de
chanson il ya une section rock qui a
toujours été présente basse batterie
guitare la basse de temps en temps
laisse la place à la contrebasse et à
part ça il ya des instruments
acoustiques donc du banjo karine est et
celle d'un alain une musique qui est
très mélodique et qui fait la part belle
aux textes
debout sur le zinc passe du rock au jazz
manouche du blues au slam à leur actif
près de deux mille concerts et une
dizaine d'albums
le dernier sorti le 13 septembre dernier
est un hommage à boris vian on a déjà eu
une aventure avec boris vian il ya
quelques années on a fait un spectacle
pour enfants sur l'abécédaire de boris
vian qui a super bien marché on a dû
l'arrêter parce que sinon on risque
encore l'album compte quinze chansons
dont cinq musiques inédites
elles ont toutes été écrites par boris
vian entre 1951 et 1958
des chansons qu'ils présentent sur scène
dans un spectacle plus intime que
d'habitude on est comme dans un salon de
années 50 et
et on est en arc de cercle je veux pas
déflorer le spectacle mais les chanteurs
sont excentrés du coup on a une vision
panoramique du groupe
un tapis une sur deux terrains de jeu et
puis est bon signe
c'est une sorte de déambulation dans la
vie d'une sorte de biographie de la vie
de tableaux lésions au travers le choix
de chance heures le groupe yvelinois
sera le 27 septembre au théâtre de la
nacelle à aubergenville avant de
sillonner la france
les îles à blanc
l'invs est toujours tenté
[Musique]